NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
You guys ready for
some more games?
Today, we will finish off
two-player games in particular.
So last time, we were in this
world of two-player games
with a polynomial-bounded
number of moves.
We proved that Othello
reversi is PSPACE complete.
All these games live in PSPACE.
And we ended with constraint
logic in the two-player case.
We proved that's
PSPACE complete.
I'll just show you
that again in a moment.
And then, in the
rest of today, we'll
talk about various other games
that don't fit in this table,
but in particular two-player
and unbounded number of moves.
So exponential number of
moves, where you get x time
completeness for
constraint logic
and for various practical games
like checkers, chess, and go.
But I won't prove all of this.
So this is bounded to
player constraint logic.
Remember, we could
simulate these formulas,
where here the setup was you
can only flip each edge once.
And in particular,
players could take
turns deciding whether
to-- white player
can set variables to true
by flipping these edges.
Black player can set variables
false by flipping those edges.
Then, if the formula
satisfied, white wins.
And that was hard and in
particular constraint logic
could simulate that problem.
So what I want to show you
next is three real-life games
that can be reduced from bounded
to player constraint logic.
And for those, we'll need
two additional facts.
One is that planar-bounded
two-player constraint
logic is PSPACE complete
with this crossover gadget.
We just need the addition
of a choice variable
with three red edges,
two in, one out.
This is what we will need.
And also that we can
make protected ORs,
an OR where you're guaranteed
at most one of these
comes in by allowing an
additional gadget which
is a free edge.
So only one of our
constructions will use this.
But in that setting,
we can make a free edge
and we need the protected OR.
So they go together well .
And so this is review
from last class.
So first real game
we're going to look at
is called Amazons
from the late '80s
but became popular in the
common material game theory
world I think in the
mid-2000s, at least that's
when I heard about it.
So the usual game is played
on an 8x8 checkerboard--
chessboard, I should say--
with four black queens and four
white queens.
Those are the Amazons.
The Amazons, as you may
know, carry bows and arrows.
So a move in this game is to
take a queen of your color,
move it in a queen-like way.
So in this example, we're moving
the clean up to this position.
And then, you fire an arrow by
another queen move from there.
So from here, we're
shooting an arrow
to this position
diagonally visible.
You're not allowed to
move through other players
or through arrows.
And you're not allowed to
shoot through other players
or through arrows.
So this the square
is destroyed forever.
So this is clearly
a bounded game.
Every move we destroy square.
You have to do both
of those things,
move between by
a non-zero amount
and then shoot an arrow
somewhere other than yourself.
You're never allowed to
land on a dead square.
So a typical game.
After you play it for a
while, it's really fun.
You should try it.
We'll end up the situation where
you've partitioned the queens
into independent components.
And so then, it's basically
a bunch of Hamiltonian cycle
problems, or longest path.
Now, these guys
have to walk around.
It's a little bit weird, because
you can shoot not exactly where
you're landing.
But in particular, you could
shoot where you just came from.
So if each of these
components-- usually they're
Hamiltonian or have
a Hamiltonian path--
and then with the queen moves.
And then, you just
sum up the areas then,
and whether white or black
has more area is the winner.
Because in general, once you
can't move, you lose the game.
The goal is to move last.
So in general, your goal is
to partition up the space
so you have more territory.
So we're going to prove PSPACE
completeness of this game using
bounded two-player
constraint logic.
So here's the basic gadgets, in
particular the idea of a wire.
We're imagining this is an
upward traveling signal.
And for it to travel
up-- think of this
as an edge reversing
from downward
pointing to upward pointing.
If the A queen has to move
down and also shoot down,
so leaving two black squares,
in that situation B can
move down and shoot down one or
move down two and shoot up one,
either way consume
these two squares
but leave two for the next guy.
This is a parity shift.
It also works if this guy
moves down, shoots down,
leaving these two squares.
Then, B can move down and
shoot diagonally and so on.
So that's our wire.
That's how we're
going to propagate
the signal, because we only
need single-use gadgets you
can do a turn, A moves
down, shoots down.
B moves down, shoots down.
C moves over, shoots diagonally.
D moves over, shoots
diagonally, and so on.
Variable gadget,
so this is what we
had on the bottom
of the construction.
This is a white or black edge.
And we'll never have to connect
black edges to anything,
so they're just hanging out.
Here, if black moves first
here and obliterates these two
squares, this wire's dead.
If white moves first then, the
white can activate the chain.
So that's going to simulate
the usual setup, where
white and black are taking
turns, setting their variables
the way they want them.
And then, if white can succeed
and satisfy the formula--
we have to get to
AND and OR gadgets.
But if white can succeed
and this guy can move down,
then B can move to this place
and shoot here, and then
move over here and shoot
into this giant room.
And then, we'll spend
tons of moves in here.
And then, come back here,
shoot there, back there,
shoot there, ther, shoot there,
and get to the other room
But if this guy does
not move down first,
this guy-- whichever
way he goes-- he'll
have to either destroy
the room he is walking to
or destroy the other room
that he could have gone.
So you only get
half of the points
if this is not activated.
And we're going to set
it up so that black
has a bunch of other moves and
some other room that's already
been cut off.
And it will be roughly
equal to one of these rooms.
And so only if you get
both of them do you win.
And because we can't
control which way B goes,
these two rooms have
to be the same size.
So you happen to win by a factor
of 2 and the number of moves.
But that's not essential to
the proof, just for symmetry.
So those are the basic gadgets.
Now, we have AND and OR
and SPLIT and CHOICE.
Usually, in NCL, we
think of AND and SPLIT
as being the same thing.
But in this setting, especially
in the bounded situation,
they're really different.
Remember, it corresponds
to whether initially
the red things are pointing in
or the blue things are pointing
in, red edges or the blue edge.
And they behave quite
differently in this setting.
So for the AND gate,
these are the two inputs.
If both of them move out of
the way, then C can move here,
shoot here.
And D can move here
and shoot there.
And if you only
move one of the two,
you won't have enough room.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
Why?
PROFESSOR: Why?
If B moves out of the way,
C can move and shoot here.
But D only has one one square.
If A moves out if the
way, C can't move.
On the other hand, an OR
gadget, these are the two inputs
and this is the output.
If either one of these
moves, we sort of already
have one square.
We just need a second
square for C to shoot into.
It could be here or here.
As long as one of them moves
out of the way, we are happy.
As a CHOICE gadget, so this
is three blues coming in
but the orientations
are different.
So a CHOICE is we have an input
coming up from the bottom.
And we want to activate one
of the two but only one.
So that corresponds
to A moving out
of the way leaving two squares.
Either B can take it and hit
those two squares or C can
take it, but only one of them.
So the same gadget does both.
That makes sense
because we're not
really distinguishing between
red and blue very much here.
SPLIT is a little bit trickier.
Let's walk through it.
A moves down.
B moves over and shoots here.
Then, C can move down
here and shoot here.
And then, D can move over
here and shoot there.
Using our queen
moves, so that leaves
these four spaces unoccupied.
Now, E can move down
here and shoot there.
F can move here and shoot there.
And now, we've got
the four squares
necessary to trigger
both H and G.
So that's a SPLIT.
And that is Amazons.
Therefore Amazons
is PSPACE complete.
Done.
Question.
AUDIENCE: What is
CHOICE needed for?
PROFESSOR: CHOICE is needed
for the crossover gadget
in particular.
Next game we'll look
at-- these proofs
are going to start
to look similar.
But I think it's helpful
to see a few examples.
This is Konane.
It's a very old game-- we
don't know how old-- invented
by Hawaiian Polynesians.
First documented in
1778 by Captain Cook.
And this was a
world championship.
No.
This is a regional
championship in 2005
that I probably lost at.
But we like to play
it with go stones.
That's not the
original formulation.
But you have two colors of
stones on a square grid.
And it's something like peg
solitaire, but with two colors.
So let me maybe show
you a bigger image.
The type of move you
can do, if you're
white you can jump over a
sequence of black stones.
You can only jump
over one at a time.
So if I had two in a row, you
wouldn't be able to jump it.
And furthermore, you're not
allowed to change directions
in a single move.
In a single move,
I could jump over
any chain of black blank
blank blank things.
And they are removed.
I captured them.
And it has to be
in a straight line.
So that's the rules.
And of course, every move
I make I capture somebody,
so it's a polynomial-bounded
number of moves.
This is the general
idea for a wire
is that with white will be
doing most of the action here.
And so white will
be jumping here.
At this point, I have
to change directions.
But luckily after I
obliterate those two pieces,
black can't do anything to me.
I'm safe between these
two black squares.
So black will do something
else, and then white
is free to start jumping in
the direction they want to.
That will be critical.
Here is a variable
where if black moves
first in this scenario, it
can capture the white thing
and prevent it from
activating this wire.
If white moves first, they
can activate the wire.
So whoever goes there
first sets the variable.
AUDIENCE: What's the start
configuration for this game?
PROFESSOR: Oh, in
the original game,
the whole board is filled
where the color of your pieces
equal the color of the
square of the checkerboard,
except for the center
two places are blank.
But we're not considering
it from the actual initial
configuration.
We're considering it from a
half-played configuration.
Because the original
configuration,
the answer is the function
of the board size.
And that's not
enough information
to be interesting from
a complexity standpoint.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any problems
that have significant
hardness results for sort
of the standard start
but generalized?
PROFESSOR: No.
In general, none
of those problems
can be hard in the sense that
we want, because they're sparse.
They have very few
inputs of a given size,
so there is no such result.
Unless you have a
variable initial setup,
like maybe games where
you-- what do you
call it-- draft your
deck in the beginning.
I mean, if you consider that
part of the initial setup,
then that could be
much more interesting.
Right.
Haven't done the
OR and the CHOICE.
So again if we--
let's do the OR.
If we are activating from
here, we can just keep going.
It'd be bad to stop here,
because then black could
capture us.
But we can go straight.
On the other hand, if we
come from this position,
we killed those two
guys who were safe
and then we can go up.
And a CHOICE gadget would
be coming-- the input
for a CHOICE would be here.
So you can jump here and
then you have a choice
whether to go up or down.
So again, same gadget
does OR and CHOICE.
And here's one gadget
that does AND, SPLIT,
and a SHIFT, which is convenient
for various ways to use it.
But what if what
it really does is
there's two traversal
paths, input 1 to output 1
and input 2 to output 2.
And they have to
happen in that order.
If you try to activate path
2, you have to stop here.
I mean, I guess you
could jump here and then
be captured that way.
If you stop here, you'll
be captured by that guy.
So that's bad news.
But if we first do the input
1 traversal-- this is safe--
and then go to the output
traversal, this guy's gone.
And so then we can
do input 2, pause,
and then go up to output 2.
So that's what the
gadget does by itself.
If we ignore what
happens out here,
then we can think of
this as an AND gate,
where first this input has
to come in, kill that guy,
and then go off Neverneverland.
And then, if the
second input comes in,
then we activate the output.
So that would be the
output of the AND gate.
That's garbage.
And these are the two inputs.
Now, there is an issue of
you have to make this one
trigger before this one.
But in all these setups,
we have these posits
where the piece can wait.
So if we have a turn gadget
right before the input,
it can just sit there and wait
for the other input to the AND
to activate.
And then, this one can go ahead
and activate the second one.
So we're very
flexible on timing.
So we can make input 1 go
before input 2 for AND.
For a SPLIT, we can just have
a white token sitting here
ready to go in that's
in a safe position.
And then, once this input
comes in, it gets output there.
Then, this one can
trigger an output there.
So we get both of the
outputs for one input.
And for a SHIFT, we do
both of these things.
We treat this is garbage.
And we have a safe
white token here.
So if this comes in,
then that can go out.
So we end up shifting by one.
And that fixes
any parity issues.
Cool.
So that's Konane
PSPACE complete.
AUDIENCE: How do you guarantee
that black doesn't screw you?
PROFESSOR: By checking
all the cases.
In general, I mean,
there's a question
of what black is doing.
Basically, within
all these gadgets,
we're preventing black
from doing anything.
So the main place where we care
about black's motion is here.
So there's going to be an
initial phase where everyone's
setting variables.
We're taking turns.
And white's going
to set half of them.
Black's going to
set half of them.
Their black is screwing you,
but in a controlled fashion.
After that, there's going
to be a pile of extra moves
that black can just do.
And black will always be forced
to do those extra useless
moves.
If we happen to satisfy
the final output
to the overall thing,
then white will
have a zillion free moves
and then white will win.
That's the idea.
But within these
gadgets, as long
as we don't do
something intelligent
like going here and then
getting captured by black,
and therefore destroying
the whole construction.
Then, white will lose, probably.
We're always careful to go
to positions that are safe.
Black cannot jump
us if we're there.
So by checking all
those cases, you
can guarantee black
doesn't hurt you.
I didn't mention what's
black doing when we're not
allowing it to play at all.
Cool.
So that's Konane.
Next, is a game
called Cross Purposes.
This is a fairly new
game by Michael Albert
who's a fun guy in the common
material game theory scene.
So again we're going
to play with go stones,
but what you should imagine
is that black stones
are towers of two blocks.
And then, you can
push them over.
So in this case, we took
this tower, pushed it up,
and so it occupied
those two spots.
But once it's pushed
over, it's kind of dead.
So we draw it in white.
And then, for example, we could
take this tower pop it over
to the right and get those two.
Now, to make this a fun
two-player game-- this
would be a natural
enough solitaire game.
But to make it a
two-player game,
we're going to have two players,
one called horizontal, which
can only do this type of
move, and another player
called vertical, which can
only do this type of move.
So what's fun here is that
it's the same black pieces used
by both players.
But one of them can
tip them left to right.
And the other can
tip them up or down.
But again it's bounded, because
once you top over a tower
it's dead.
So this is going to be
PSPACE complete by reduction
from bounded two-player
constraint logic.
So some-- question.
AUDIENCE: What's the
goal of the game?
PROFESSOR: The goal the
game is to move last.
If you can't move, you lose.
And that can be asymmetric.
Some pieces are only going
to be flippable up or down.
A lot of games
have that feature.
It's called normal play,
in fact, it's so common.
That the last
player to move wins.
So a wire is going to
look something like this.
In general, I think vertical
is the player that we're
rooting for, and
we're trying to decide
whether vertical can win.
And we're going to
set up horizontal--
unlike the previous game--
we're going to set up horizontal
in a position that it never
has any moves except the one
that you give it right then.
So the idea is that as
soon as we move A down,
then horizontal has a
move, namely the playing B.
And then, we have
a move and so on.
So that will trigger.
That better not
stop at any point.
We always want to set it up so
when we're switching gadgets,
it's our turn to move,
because the horizontal player
will never have
another move to make.
This is what it
looks like after.
I mean, things are
just filling in
if you've partially
filled in this thing.
Here's how we make a variable.
So here in the initial
phase of the game,
horizontal will have moves.
Horizontal could play this,
filling those two squares,
preventing us from
playing this wire.
So whoever goes here first
will claim the thing.
And if it's vertical, then
it triggers the true value.
We can also terminate
a wire like this.
This is always good for us.
We can just trigger it
whenever we want as vertical.
So we need that for
free edges, which
we need for the protected OR.
So to clarify or to fix what I
said before, for the initial n
moves, horizontal
and vertical are
going to exchange variables,
take turns picking them.
At that point onwards,
horizontal has no moves
except the one
right after-- we're
forcing horizontal to
always play the way we want.
So after this is done, then
as soon as you move this,
then horizontal
has a unique move.
So it will cooperate.
Horizontal has to cooperate
with us to fill in wires.
So here is a protected OR.
So if we trigger this, then this
triggers, then this triggers,
then this triggers, then
that triggers, and so on.
So that's all good.
The reason it's a
protected OR-- the trouble
if we activated this twice, so
first we activate through here,
and then we activate
here, and then here.
And then, as vertical,
we move B down.
Now, horizontal has no move.
So that would be bad
news, if we sort of waste
a trigger like that.
And so that's why we
need a protected OR,
where only at most one of
the two sides will trigger.
CHOICE gadget is the same,
but rotated 90 degrees.
And that makes a big difference,
because horizontal and vertical
are flipped.
So input is here.
So if we trigger this, and
then this, and then this,
and then this.
Then, as vertical,
we get to choose
whether this one activates
or this one activates.
So it's important to
make it the right player.
And here's the omega gadget
that does AND, SPLIT, and SHIFT.
If we try to activate
input 2, these topple over.
This topples down.
And now, horizontal
gets a choice.
And horizontal's going
to be mean and push B
over and prevent this thing
from activating, because it
wants to prevent you from
doing whatever you're doing.
Because eventually, you're
going to get to a place
where you win, where
you have a single move
and then horizontal
doesn't have a move.
So that's in horizontal's
interest to block you.
But if you first did
all of these toppling,
topple this down, over down,
over down, over down, over.
Then, in particular, you
put a white token here
and so B won't be
able to do that.
So when you activate these
guys, D will have to go over
and out you go.
So and then, it's the
same thing either putting
a free wire in input 2 and/or
ignoring the output from output
1, we get AND, SPLIT, and SHIFT.
And I think that's it
for Cross Purposes.
Question.
AUDIENCE: I probably
misinterpreted.
Did you show TURN gadget?
PROFESSOR: I maybe did
not show a TURN gadget.
There's a TURN gadget.
Good.
I didn't talk about it.
It works in the obvious way.
But, yeah, it is
definitely a little tricky
to make sure you can do it.
But it works.
AUDIENCE: Back to the
normal play condition,
if you use games different
from the [INAUDIBLE]
version of the rule set?
PROFESSOR: In
general, those games
are different when you
can't move then you win.
But from a PSPACE
completeness perspective,
it should be the same.
It's really whether you are
starting the quantifying
sequence with an
exists or a for all.
And both end up with
the class PSPACE.
So there may be a
way to distinguish.
But at our level of granularity,
we're not distinguishing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
whether it's PSPACE
complete for arbitrary setups
with only black starting
tokens?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
I see.
No obstacles.
AUDIENCE: It's a more
natural starting place,
than starting with a--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's definitely not known.
I think it would be cool to
think about only black tokens,
no initial whites.
All right.
So that's all I want
to say about PSPACE.
I think we're done with PSPACE.
We first did PSPACE here,
then PSPACE here last class,
and then PSPACE here.
So now we're going to move
up to EXPTIME, 2 players,
unbounded number of moves.
EXPTIME turns out to
be the right class.
Oh.
I lied.
I have one more PSPACE class,
which I don't have slides for.
This is a short topic,
but it's a cool one,
I think something that
deserves more study.
But at the moment there
are no natural games
like real-life
games that have been
shown to fall into this class
or to be complete in this class.
So this is stochastic games.
The idea is you're playing
against a random opponent.
So you have two players, and
one of the players is random.
So it's hard to identify
with randomness.
So the other player is you.
Your goal is to win the game.
And you know that your player's
just flipping a coin every time
and playing randomly,
say uniformly
or some distribution
that's known to you.
Think of games where you're
rolling dice, or drawing cards,
or there's some random
aspect to the game.
How hard are these games?
Well, what's been studied--
this is a [INAUDIBLE] paper--
is for bounded two-player
stochastic games.
The answer is PSPACE again.
So, for example, here's a game,
a formula game, stochastic SAT.
We want to know is
there a move such
that for a randomly chosen
move-- I like this notation.
We have exist and for all.
Backwards R is a
random quantifier.
There exists an x3
such that a random x4,
so this is uniform random over
0 and 1, the binary choice 01.
We want the probability--
this gives a distribution.
We want the probability of
the formula being satisfied
being greater than a half.
I'm guessing you could pump that
up to be with high probability.
But just deciding
whether you could
win by probability strictly more
than half, is PSPACE complete.
So this is cool.
And to me intuitively
randomness should be weaker
than an adversarial
player, where
you replace these with for all.
But it turns out they behave
roughly the same essentially
by a probability
amplification argument.
It's a little too
detailed to go into here.
And so far, there
are no reductions
from this to what I
would call natural games.
There are a few
examples in the paper,
but none around rolling dice.
I would love to apply this
to like playing Tetris,
or in the paper they
mention backgammon
as a candidate,
something like that,
where you'd like to
get PSPACE completeness
in a bounded setting.
So throwing that out there is an
interesting direction to study,
but I'll end it there.
Now, we can go to EXPTIME,
two players, unbounded game,
adversarial player,
no randomness.
And we get EXPTIME completeness.
So we're going to start
out with-- I guess,
similar to what we do it down
here-- I'm going to start
with some formula games
which are EXPTIME complete
and then some graph games
that are EXPTIME complete,
then constraint logic game
which is EXPTIME complete.
And along the way will prove
something some hardness.
There are fewer results here,
in general, I would say.
In particular, I don't
have a good example
of using constraint logic
to prove a fun game hard,
though they probably exist.
We just haven't
gotten there yet.
So it's more open problems.
But there are a lot of cool
base problems out there.
And this field started by a
paper by Stockmeyer and Chandra
in 1979.
And it's been the basis
for pretty much all
EXPTIME hardness proofs.
EXPTIME hardness is
really cool, because it
implies exponential time.
Any problems EXPTIME hard
cannot be solved faster than
exponential time.
Whereas all these
other classes, we
need to assume P does not equal
NP or P is not equal to PSPACE.
P we know does
not equal EXPTIME.
So these games require
exponential time.
It's kind of fun.
And I'm pretty sure the first
results in this category
were these games.
So it's power of games.
So in general, we're going
to have some formula, maybe
a couple formulas.
But definitely we have
a variable assignment.
And the state of
the game is going
to be a variable
assignment and who's
going to move next, player 1
or player 2, black or white.
Again, we'll use that notation.
And we're going to start
with some variable arbitrary
variable assignment.
That's part of the initial state
of the game, the board if you
will.
And in general, you can
set variables to 0 or 1
as many times as you like.
That's what distinguishes
this from bounded games.
And all of these games
are going to be partisan,
a term we used last
class, so meaning
we're going to have black
and white variables.
And I'm going to
cheat a little bit.
There's going to be
one variable that's
black and white, but
only in one of the games.
So we'll get there.
So black player can only
change the black variables.
The white player can only
change the white variables,
except for how I'm
going to cheat.
So let's start.
These games are very
creatively named.
First one's called G1.
And it's amazing how
consistent the literature
is about the naming
of these games.
So in G1, I move my
player is to set all
the variables of your color.
So if you're white, you're going
to set all the white variables.
If black, you're going to
set all black variables.
And set here means you get to
choose whether it's 0 or 1.
So you're just going to
completely rewrite all
of the variables of your color.
And then, here's the cheat.
We're also going to have
a single variable that's
shared between black and white.
Call it t.
And it's going to be 0 if
it's a player 2's move,
1 if it's player 1's move.
I mean, it doesn't
really matter.
But I guess 1 and 1 is nice.
So that's the moves.
What's the goal of the game?
You're going to lose the
game if, by making your move,
you satisfy a common between
the two players 4DNF formula.
So there's one
formula in the game.
It's DNF, which is very
simple to think about.
It's just a bunch of options.
If this happens, you lose.
It's an OR with
various conditions.
So you want to
move in such a way
that you do not satisfy
that formula every time.
And in each move, you can
rewrite all your variables.
But this formula
does involve t, which
lets you care about
who's turn it was.
So that's cool, very clean.
I mean, the players have
a lot of power here.
This is the first
game proved hard.
A little tricky to work
with, because in most games
you can't set all the
variables at once.
Generally, you're only setting
one variable at a time.
So all the other
games are going to be
setting one variable at a time.
At this point,
we're just defining.
Then, we'll use these games
to prove some hardness.
G2, the next game, is
a move was going to be
set one variable of your color.
So in particular, if you set the
variable to its original value,
that's like passing.
So passing is
allowed in this game.
Passing is also allowed here.
You could not change
any of the variables.
You wouldn't win in that case.
You only win if your
opponent loses in this setup.
When the question
is can you win.
In this case, we're going
to have a win condition.
In this case, white
and black have
their own winning formulas.
They're in 12DNF, still
DNF but a little bigger.
And if you satisfy your formula
at the end of your turn,
you win and vice versa.
And move is just change
one variable at a time.
So that's a very useful game.
Next is G3.
A slight variation
to G3, we're going
to flip one variable
of your color.
And then, we're going to lose if
you satisfy your 12DNF formula.
One thing to keep in mind.
Losing and winning
are quite different,
because losing is essentially
negating the formula, which
turns DNF into DNF.
So you can think
of this as winning.
In the CNF condition,
you could think of this
as losing in a DNF condition.
But they're not interchangeable.
So here we flipped
between DNF and DNF.
But we've also changed
the definition of a move.
A flip, you're not
allowed to pass.
You must change a variable
to its opposite value.
Here, we're allowed
to just pass.
So we changed the move
definition and the win
condition.
That is also hard.
This is a common one.
I would say most EXPTIME
hardness proofs use this one.
G4.
Move is going to be like this.
You can set one
variable of your color.
And here, we're going to
have a common win condition.
This is nice.
You win if satisfy a
common 12DNF formula.
Whoops.
13DNF.
We need a little more.
So every move,
we're both checking
the same formula in this case.
And here, the set
happens to win.
So it's a variation of G2.
G5 does not exist.
G6-- there is a G5 in
the paper, but it's
a generalization of G6.
So I'll tell you
what is in a second.
Not important.
So G6, same thing for the move.
You set one of your variables
to whatever you want.
But we're going to make
it asymmetric in the sense
that-- and this will be very
helpful for constraint logic--
player 1 wins-- player 1 is
the one that we care about.
We're trying to decide whether
they win-- if anyone satisfies
a particular formula.
So there's one CNF formula.
If it's ever satisfied,
player 1 wins.
If it's never satisfied,
you get a tie.
And we want to know whether
player 1 can force a win.
So this is very compatible
with this sort of thing
we were doing before
with it was the game
problem from last class, but in
particular the constraint logic
games.
So we'll use G6 for
constraint logic.
G3 is most other proofs.
So these are all EXPTIME
complete formula games.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: All right.
I'm a know; little
confused about G1.
So I can pass by just setting
down any of my variables,
right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So then,
how could I ever lose?
Because if--
AUDIENCE: You can lose if
the turn variable changed
satisfies the [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
PROFESSOR: Well, it changes
every time so, yeah, right.
I think you could set your
variables in such a way when
it's the opponents turn,
no matter what they do,
the formula becomes
satisfied and then they lose.
Yeah.
Good.
AUDIENCE: But then it
became satisfied on my turn.
Sorry.
PROFESSOR: But t was
a different value.
So when it's your turn, you
set t to 0 or set t to 1.
And so then, maybe the
formula's not satisfied.
When it's the opponents
turn, even if they pass,
t is set to 0.
Yes. t is part of the formula.
AUDIENCE: Where
does the 12 come up?
Is that from the previous?
PROFESSOR: I think it's
from the previous result.
Yeah.
Didn't we have an 11 or 12?
AUDIENCE: It was 12.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
All right.
In case, you prefer
real games, as I do.
Here is a physical
instantiation--
it could be many of the games.
The one they chose
to highlight was G4.
So this is a game called Peek.
And that name has
been reappropriated
for many other games, which
we'll talk about in a moment.
But the idea is you
have a bunch of trays.
Each tray has a
bunch of holes in it.
Everybody knows where
all the holes are.
Each tray has
exactly two positions
in all the way and
out all the way.
It's like here.
And there are white
trays and black trays.
So G4, white player can take any
of the trays of their variable,
and if they want to,
toggle its state.
They can either push it in
or pull it out or leave it
as it is.
And then, you're going to
win if, viewed from above,
there's a hole that sees all
the way down to the ground.
So you could put
something red here.
And if you see red at
the top, then you've
satisfied the DNF formula.
It's common between the two.
So the first player
to make a move
where you could see a
hole the way through,
that is expressing DNF formula.
So that's kind of a
fun way, geometric way,
to think about these games.
And you could adapt it
to all of these games,
just with slightly
different geometric setups.
We'll see one in a little bit.
Cool.
I have here the next
thing to mention
is why are all these
games in EXPTIME.
I think that's
worth talking about.
The idea is pretty simple.
All these games-- I mean,
you can represent a state
in a polynomial number of bits.
It's just the current setting
of the variables and maybe
whose turn it is.
Therefore, there are
an exponential number
of possible states.
And the approach is basically
to build the entire state graph
and then rank for each
position whether it's
a win for one player or a
win for the other player.
And I think the
easiest way to think
about this is you start
with all the configurations
that satisfy the win condition.
You call those
mate-in-0 positions.
And then, from there
in exponential time
you can compute, find
all of the moves, where
all the places where you can
make a move in any response
lead you to a win position.
And those are the
mate-in-1 positions.
Or in two ply, one
move, one pair of moves.
And so on and so forth.
And so then, at
most you are going
to be mate in exponential,
because they're only
exponentially many states.
So the longest mate path
is going to be exponential.
So you can do like 4k equals 0
to the total number of states,
which is an exponential
compute mate-in-k.
And then, you've characterized
the whole state space
in nearly exponential time.
And now you know which
ones are winning states.
And then, you check whether
yours is one of them.
So there's probably
other ways to do it.
You could probably start from
your initial configuration.
But this makes it clear that
it's at most exponential time
that you'll be spending.
Not polynomial space, because
we're building the entire graph
here for this to work.
We have to remember for all
the states that we visited,
so we can check for duplicates.
So that's intuitively why we're
an exponential time bigger
than PSPACE, assuming
PSPACE does not equal
EXPTIME, which we believe.
Cool.
So let's do some
graph games next.
I have two games to mention
and a proof for one of them.
First game is based
on Hamiltonian cycle.
So this is a funny kind of game.
And the claim is that you can do
this for a lot of different NP
complete problems.
But in general, we have a graph.
Every edge of the graph
is either black or white.
And black player can
only play black edges.
White player can only
play black edges.
In addition, every edge
either in or out, in the graph
or currently out of the graph.
And that's what these variables
are going to correspond to.
I mean, we're going to convert
into a corresponding game.
In this case, it's going
to be a G6 style game.
So the winning condition
is that the set of in edges
form a Hamiltonian
cycle in the graph.
So you could think in
means in the cycle,
out means not in the cycle.
If we ever get to a
state where the in edges
form a Hamiltonian
cycle, player 1 wins.
Player 2's goal is
to try to avoid that.
Player 2 can only
control the black edges.
Player 1 can only
control the white edges.
At the end of each turn, you
can change, if you want to,
one of the edges
between in and out
and one of the
edges of your color.
So I'm just going to leave it at
that, because the proof is not
terribly interesting.
No gadgets, but
this next game is
I think a lot more fun,
more surprisingly hard.
And it has a nice clean
reduction also from G3.
So what's the game?
We are given three graphs
on the same vertices.
So really you can think of this
as a three-edge colored graph.
There's the red graph, the
blue graph, the green graph,
same set of vertices.
And we are going to
have tokens on vertices.
And we're going to have
at most one per vertex.
There are white tokens
and black tokens.
A move by a player
is going to, call it,
slide a token, exactly one of
them, of your color along path
in one of the graphs.
There's three of them.
And that slide has to
satisfy a few conditions.
One condition which is
that the target vertex
you get to and all intermediate
vertices that you follow
along the path must be empty.
They should have no tokens.
So you pick up any
token of your color--
you pick a color
red, green, or blue--
and you follow a red path
or you follow a green path
or you follow a blue path.
As long as that path doesn't
hit any other tokens,
then you drop your
token, erase it
from where it was
originally, and you
keep making moves like that.
What about the win condition?
We look at a player-- I'm going
to come the players 1 and 2.
Player i will win if they
get one of their tokens
to a node in the win set WI.
So also we're going to color
the nodes as winning for white
or winning for black.
And if you ever get a token to
a winning spot for your color,
games over.
You win.
So this is a pretty
natural token-sliding game.
As EXPTIME complete, very hard.
And this one we're
going to proof.
So this is a variable gadget.
So we're going to
reduce from G3.
I think I said that.
This one.
So G3, a move
corresponds to you're
forced to flip a
variable of your color.
Although we could switch
that to the other version.
And you're going to lose the
game if you satisfy your DNF
formula.
So there's lots of edges here.
But in particular, there's
solid edges, dashed edges,
and the dotted edges.
That's red, green, and blue.
This is before color journals.
Question.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
catch what the purpose
of coloring the edges is.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
It's basically to
decompose the graph
into a bunch of
different types of paths.
So when you follow
a path, it must
be a path of a single color.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you can only follow the solid
path or follow a dashed path
or follow a dotted path.
You can't mix edges
of different colors.
So that's the three graphs.
So what's going on?
We've got a white token
here, black token here,
white token here.
This is a win
position for white.
These are win
positions for black.
So there's a lot of
things going on here.
But the main idea is that white
can move the token to here.
That corresponds to
EXPTIME being false.
Or it can move it to here.
That corresponds to
EXPTIME being true.
And that's essentially all
you can do in this picture.
Why?
Because if this guy moves
to here, for example,
then black can win.
Black can go along this
path and get to a win state.
And symmetrically, if white
also goes off the track,
then black can go
to the win state.
Also, we had to put this vertex
here, put this token here,
to make that true.
You might worry,
maybe black tries
to move out of that position to
there or to there or to there.
But then white will
win by going like that.
So under optimal play, if you
don't make silly losing moves,
all you can do is move the white
token between here and here.
And I didn't say it,
but the path here
is supposed to be a
non-zero length path.
So you have to move your token.
And therefore, that
represents this constraint
that you must put the variable.
You must flip exactly one
variable of your color.
So that's the variable gadget.
And for a while, that's
just going to happen.
But now we have to
implement the win condition
or the lose condition.
So that's this thing.
This is a clause.
This is a DNF clause.
Is it x3 is false
and y5 is true.
In that case, we
want to lose or win.
It doesn't particularly
matter here.
We want to lose, I guess.
Obviously, black can't move
first in this configuration,
because then white
could just win.
So black can't move first, so
what can happen in this gadget
is that white must move
here because you're not
allowed to collide.
Once you move there,
the threat is that white
will win in the next turn.
So black must move up.
And then, if this is
empty, white can move here.
It could actually move to
here, because that's a path.
And then, the threat
is white will win.
So black must move up.
Also, there's a black win
there, but we'll get to that.
Actually, I'll do it now.
So if this was blocked by
x3, because x3 is currently
set to true, then you won't
be able to move this way.
So you'll basically
be stuck here.
And then, black
can win like that.
So you don't want to
activate this gadget
unless this is clear.
Similarly, we don't
want to activate it
unless this is clear.
So if we're up to
here, then white
can move up, threatening to win.
Therefore, black must move up.
And then, if this is clear,
white can move up to there.
And then, black has to go
there to prevent this win.
But white can win that way.
So white is going to
win if this clause was
satisfied or unsatisfied.
And I'm a little confused about
how many times we negated.
But I think you get the spirit.
And if this DNF clause is
satisfied, then white wins.
And you can have a bunch of
these clauses just sitting
around.
These are all vertices
unique to the clause,
except for these
guys, which are shared
with the variable gadgets here.
So those are the same
as these vertices.
They're all glued together.
No planarity here.
Cool.
So that's EXPTIME completeness
of this game called Block.
All right.
This is a little ambitious.
But the next one
I'd like to prove
is a real-life classic
game, namely checkers.
This is most of the
proof in one slide.
It's a little bit complicated.
But let me give you
the high level idea.
It's actually a
really cool proof.
It's also from my birth years.
So it's cool.
So don't worry
about this too much,
but our construction is going
to be this little square
inside this little square.
And then there's
this giant spiral
outside that will cause
everything to self-destruct
when the game ends.
I'll talk about that later.
Let's focus in first
on what's happening
within this little square.
But that will be the context,
and we'll get to that again.
So inside the square
is this thing.
So I mean, I think the
perspective is from white.
So the goal is for white to win.
And in checkers, there's
two types of pieces.
And the circles are
going to be pieces
that are going this way for
white and that way for black.
And the squares are
going to be kings.
They can move up or down.
So white and has some
variables that it can set
between true and false up here.
Black has some
variables that can
be set between true or false.
I didn't mention, but we
are going to be playing G3.
We are going to
be simulating G3.
So a move is going to be
forcing to flip something.
And we're going to lose
if the formula ends up
being satisfied.
So then there's this
computation done in the middle.
Basically, each of
these boxes is going
to correspond to a DNF clause.
What makes it tricky
is each clause
involves some black variables
and some white variables.
And those are going to
behave quite differently.
But this construction is
going to make that happen.
And overall, let's see.
Where to go?
Let's start with
the variable gadget.
So this is a white
variable gadget.
Black variable
gadget is symmetric
with all the colors
flipped I believe.
Yeah.
That should be fine.
And the key actor is
this king right here.
I've drawn it at
the intersection.
But it could be on the t
position or the f position.
t corresponds to
variables being said true.
f corresponds to the
variables being set false.
And so most of the game is going
to be all the players moving
their kings back and
forth between these t
and f positions.
Those will correspond
to flipping
a variable of your color.
Now, constantly you're
worrying about the threats.
These attack zones and
defend paths are the threats.
And if ever a
threat is satisfied,
somebody's going to win.
And the game will end.
So when that happens, players
in the variable position
can choose to activate a
variable of their color.
And the way you would
do that, a key rule
which you may have
forgotten about checkers,
is that if you can
capture you must capture.
So that's how we're going
to force the opponent
to do lots of things
we want them to do.
If we move this white token up
and to the right, then suddenly
this black token can capture.
And it must capture along the
unique path boom, boom, boom,
boom.
Assuming that we're
in the true position,
he must jump there, jump
there, jump there, and activate
some stuff down here.
Conversely, if we're
in the false position,
we're going to move this
B guy up and to the left.
And then, black token will have
to go off into this position.
So far so good.
Now, so this variable may occur
in several different clauses.
There's one clause that matters,
because this is a DNF thing.
We're just trying to prove that
one clause has been satisfied.
So white's going to want to
send things that satisfy it.
Black is going to want to
send its variables that
cause it to be not satisfied.
So there's going to be
some white variables
and some black variables
involved in this one clause.
But we need the ability to
send the copy of this variable
to the clause that matters.
So the threatening
player, white,
is going to be sending their
thing to a particular cause.
They do that using
this fork gadget.
So if you're coming
from up here,
you jump here, and jump here.
Black jumps here.
And that's the end
of black's turn.
Now, white is going to move
this position to either H or I,
forcing black to go
follow the next path.
So white's always in
control for this path.
There's going to be a
symmetric thing where
black is in control.
And black and send their token
to where they want it to go,
one of these squares.
Cool.
Now, maybe at this
point I should
mention that there are these
letters here, MWD and MBD.
And this is relevant to
the overall architecture
of the game.
What we're essentially trying
to do is get free moves.
Free moves will win
the game, because
of the spiral on the outside.
But before I get to
the spiral, here's
a way to generate free moves.
Suppose right here I'm going
to throw in a whole bunch--
think of infinity-- copies of
this gadget, so-called white
delay.
So black is forced to jump here
and just keeps going through.
There's no options for black.
It just has to keep going.
But after that move,
white has a penalty,
because white is forced
to capture that token.
So white essentially lost a
move sometime in the future.
As long as there are still
capture moves it's OK.
But that's kind
of bad for white.
And there's a symmetric
version for black.
I didn't bring the picture,
but it's pretty similar.
And black will be forced
afterwards to jump.
So the point is if we
essentially stopped
here, black would win actually.
Because there's
so many moves here
that white is forced
to waste, they'll
end up being able to win
the whole game in a way
that I will get to.
For that reason, you better
not trigger this thing
unless the king is
in the right spot.
Otherwise, black will stop
there and then black will win.
But there's a matching
MBD down here for black.
And so we're forced
to use both of them.
Then, they cancel
each other out.
Because if black
has n free moves
and white as n
free moves, they'll
just make all those captures
and then get back to the game.
So, in general, the
gadgets use these things
to force you to not stop in
the middle of the construction.
The heart of the matter is
this gadget, the clause.
So there's numbers here.
If you look closely, these
are 1's and then these are
2's and then these are 3's.
So the idea is let's
suppose that there
are three white variables
and two black variables
in this clause that
you can generalize.
That's what the figure shows.
So the idea is that first
white's trying to win.
So it's going to
send its variables
of the appropriate truth
assignment into the one clause.
It's going to
activate whichever one
happens to be glued to the
one clause first or the one
position.
And what will happen is the
white token will go here.
I forgot to mention
we've switched colors
from white to black.
That's because
there's a color change
gadget, where you can convert
white wires into black wires.
So don't worry about it.
So now we have a white token
that captures all these pieces.
Notice it captures
this one, which will
enable the two path next time.
So it is first you send in this.
It just stops,
nothing to do there.
Then, we send in the 2's.
And if this has
been done already,
so this is basically a
conjunction of 1 and 2.
2 will be able to get here
if and only if both 1 and 2
are set.
Also capture this position
and this position,
enabling both of these 3's.
Basically, we have two
copies of the 3 wire
just because the opponent
could mess things up
for us by moving one of these.
Black can move this over here.
And then, we're kind of annoyed.
But we have two
copies for redundancy.
So even if black messes up
one of them, we'll be OK.
The worry is after you activate
this thing black has a turn.
And so maybe instead of
doing something else, black
could just move this.
But we have enough redundancy.
That won't hurt us.
Finally, if we can send
1, 2, and 3 together,
then black will waste n moves.
And so white is in the lead.
And then, white will
win the game in a way
that I haven't shown you.
Conversely, black has a blocking
strategy, a defense strategy,
which is after 2 has
activated, if black
has either of these variable
set to the right value,
they can trigger them with a
corresponding black variable
gadget.
And then, the white
token will come up here
and hit this gadget MWD, which
is a whole bunch of these.
And then, white is behind.
And then, black will
immediately win.
Before white gets to do
this, black will win.
So overall structure make sense?
Basically, this gadget
is active as soon
as the white player
sends down the one thing
and then sends
down the two thing.
And then, if black happens
to have a response which
blocks it, what
that corresponds to
is that one of the
black variables
is in the wrong setting
for this clause.
Then, black will have a defense
strategy and win the game.
And so you only want
to activate a thing
if all the black variables
are in the correct setting
currently and the
white variables
in the correct setting, so you
could do the 1, 2, 3, and then
win.
And symmetrically, there are
things like this for black.
But that is the game.
Now, let me tell
you how once you
have n free moves, how
you could win the game.
This is the outer spiral.
So everything
we're talking about
was in here very far away from
the spiral, like n squared away
or something.
And the spiral in more
detail looks like this.
We have a whole bunch of kings,
and white king, black king.
And if you have a
bunch of free moves--
you don't actually need
very many free moves.
It's like five or something.
But they didn't feel
like computing it,
so they just called it x
and then figured out for x.
You can make a few moves
and get from this position
to this position.
So far so good.
Still have a free move.
Iam going to move this A
king to the B position.
At that point, black
has a forced jump.
Now, they may have
other forced jumps.
We'll just just sit
there and wait for them
to do all their forced jumps.
And then, black will have
to make this jump, capturing
one of these kings.
So this guy's basically
to prevent you
from jumping that way.
So this guy moves down, which
forces this guy to jump here.
And then, from here, you
can jump here, here, here,
here, here, so satisfying.
Take all the black
kings on the outside.
Now, you own the
entire spiral, which
is a huge number of things.
The number of
rings of the spiral
is greater than the
number of pieces in there.
And also, these things
are very far away.
So you have plenty of moves.
So whatever's
happening in here--
chaos could be
happening-- you can
rearrange the white spiral into
a bunch of white rectangles.
And it's already been shown
conveniently that if you have
n white rectangles
in this sense, less
or equal to n
pieces, then you win.
So it doesn't matter
what's in here.
You can come in
and use each ring
to destroy one black
token at a time.
And game over.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Isn't that fun?
So that's checkers
EXPTIME complete.
A very cool proof.
There are details I didn't show.
There's a parity shift,
a few other things.
But that's pretty
much everything.
And that's the power of G3.
I'll just show
pictures for chess.
It's even more complicated.
But chess is also
EXPTIME complete.
Now, I mean, both
checkers and chess
in the real game sometimes
in some versions of the rules
it says you can make at
most 200 moves or 500
moves or something.
Those games are of
course PSPACE complete,
if you add an artificial
move bound of n or something.
But if you don't, the
natural game I think
is when you don't bound
the number of moves,
then they become
EXPTIME complete.
This is also from G3.
That's I'll say about chess.
AUDIENCE: Do you know in
chess what pieces are used?
PROFESSOR: I think it's just
pawns and bishops, which
is pretty cool.
One of these figures--
AUDIENCE: Oh.
It's on the left.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
White pawn, black pawn,
white bishop, black bishop.
I'm pretty sure
that's all of them.
But it's a little hard to
tell him from this figure.
I think you need a better
scan to know which are which.
And
This paper's a little hard to
find, but I got a scanned copy.
Go is EXPTIME hard.
So how many people know Go?
Good.
Almost everyone.
So Go is a little
funny, because you might
think it's a bounded game.
Every time you place a
token, you consume area.
But captures remove area, and
furthermore kos are the action.
So kos are these threats that
when I capture and someone else
can capture me back.
And you can flip back and forth
from those types of states.
There are actually
different rules for Go.
The Japanese rule set
says that you are not
allowed to repeat the
position you were just at.
And this is the
subtlety of a ko.
So this is the
canonical simplest ko.
So if you move white here,
you capture this stone.
And under Japanese
rules, you're not
allowed to repeat the
previous position, which
means you're not allowed
to immediately play back
here and capture this stone.
You can see why.
It'd be kind of a boring game
if you just went back and forth
capturing the same guy.
But as long as you
play anywhere else,
then you can come
back and capture.
That's the ko threat.
That game is in EXPTIME.
And Go is EXPTIME complete
under Japanese rules.
In some sense, because
the number of states
is still only
exponential, you just
need to remember the
current state and the very
previous state.
Because the ko rule is
that you're not allowed
to repeat the previous state.
In the USA and China, there
is something called a super ko
rule, which is that
you're not allowed
to repeat any previous
state of the game ever seen.
That means that you are not
necessarily still in EXPTIME,
because you might need to
remember all past states, which
could be exponentially long.
So it's like double
the exponential size.
In general, you are in EXPSPACE.
And it's an open problem
whether Go with super ko
is EXPSPACE complete.
Currently, best known lower
bound is EXPTIME hardness.
I won't cover the gadgets here.
I mean, it's even more subtle,
because you can't really
be capturing.
It's all about ko threats.
Or you can't really
be adding pieces.
You have to constantly
be capturing,
because you must
conserve volume.
You're running for
exponential time.
It would be quite an
interesting game to watch.
But it's a reduction
I think from G3 again.
That's Go.
Let me tell you a little
bit about constraint logic.
So we got a question.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I was just wondering
if you're allowed
to use superpolynomial
reductions for EXPTIME purpose.
PROFESSOR: So in
fact, all the proofs
I've seen in this world
use LOGSPACE, which is even
stronger than polynomial time.
I don't know why.
Probably just because they can.
And it's slightly better.
It makes sense to use LOGSPACE
reductions for PSPACE hardness.
But they ended up still
doing LOGSPACE reductions
for EXPTIME hardness.
For my purposes, I think
polynomial time would be fine.
You could imagine using
a little bit more time.
Definitely you don't want
to use exponential time,
because that wouldn't
preserve a lower bound.
But you could use
quasi-polynomial or polynomial
spaces or some crazy thing.
But all the claims
I've made don't even
need polynomial time reductions.
It's pretty strong.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That rule
confuses me a lot.
So that means I can't ever
go in the erased area?
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
You could play here as long
as something else changed.
You cannot repeat the
entire board configuration.
So the local
configuration can repeat.
So as long as something
else has changed,
then you can play here.
AUDIENCE: But then it's
the same rule, right?
PROFESSOR: It's the same rule.
But if you have five of
these, so in the ko rule,
as long as you're
basically playing them
in a different order, you
can keep playing around
and ko, ko, ko.
But in the super-ko
rule, at some point,
you're going to run
out of ko patterns.
And at some point, you won't
be able to repeat something.
And that changes how
the game behaves.
Of course, we don't have a
hardness proof for that case,
or a stronger hardness proof.
It's subtle.
Two-player constraint
logic unbounded
is also EXPTIME complete.
This is a reduction from G6.
You can set one of your
variables however you want.
And player 1 is going to win
if we satisfy a CNF formula.
So the formula is out
here or here or here.
This is a white variable.
This is a black variable.
The only difference is
this edge is white here.
This edge is black there.
So the idea is this can
be set left to right.
If it's left, that
corresponds to false.
If it's to the right,
it corresponds to true.
And so most of the
time, players are just
going to be flipping their
edges back and forth.
It'd be a pretty boring game.
But at some point, there's
this constant threat network,
which is if the
formula is satisfied,
then the white player is
going to be able to win.
How do they win?
First thing they do
is lock a variable.
So this is pointing to the
true state-- sorry, also left
and right pictures are
symmetric, so symmetric
that we didn't even
draw it in the book.
So I reflected the image and
all the letters are backwards.
So let's say the variable's
pointing to the right.
So white is going to
lock the variable,
prevent it from flipping
anymore, by flipping this edge.
Now, we enter attack face.
And lots of things happen.
So this is a SPLIT gadget.
So immediately,
for example, black
could flip here and
start winning the game.
There's a long path here.
It's slow, so it's a long path.
But eventually black
will win the game.
The timer starts
ticking now potentially,
if black chooses to
follow that path.
Simultaneously, white is
going to flip this guy,
then flip this guy,
and then flip this guy
and activate the formula.
Now, it's a little
awkward, because we
needed 1, 2, 3, 4 moves
to trigger the formula.
We basically want to
consume four moves of black
so that things remain balanced.
And that's this
1, 2, 3, 4 flips.
If black does not
flip all these edges,
then white can flip this
and then flip this and then
flip this and then
instantly win.
That's the fast win track.
So to prevent that, black
must flip this edge.
It can't flip this edge
until it's flipped this one.
It can't flip this one
So as soon as you
lock a variable,
black must respond
with A. At that point,
white can afford to flip here.
And black must respond
with B. And then flip here,
black must respond with
C. And then flip here,
black must respond-- I guess,
flip here first and then
flip B. And then you can
activate the formula.
So then white and black
are balanced again.
What's cool about that is it
means white cannot only lock
this variable but lock
all of the variables.
Every variable
behaves the same way.
And the goal for white is to
get all the variables locked
so it can start
triggering the formula.
So every time you
lock a variable,
black is forced to respond
in a particular way.
And so after that, white can
lock the next variable, both
the white ones and the black
ones, locks all of them.
And now, the formula's
basically primed, ready to go.
The variables can't
change anymore.
And now, we're in
full attack mode.
Cool.
And then, the formula happens.
Meanwhile, this slow win is
probably happening, fusing.
And we set up the formula
so that if it's satisfied,
you end up flipping the win edge
in a certain amount of time.
And this is slightly longer.
So if you don't end up
satisfying the formula,
black wins.
And then, it was
not a valid threat.
You shouldn't have
triggered this attack mode.
There's another threat
here, the slower win.
So I assume that people
were flipping these edges.
But it could be actually
black flips A early.
If it does that, then
white will eventually
win through that path.
So this win path is just
to prevent A from flipping
before it's locked.
And the timing is
to setup right.
Obviously, lots of
timing issues here,
so we have to build an
equalizer gadget that ends up
slowing down the traversal
of an edge basically
in a particular way.
And these are all of
the vertices need.
It's a fair number, including
some white and black edges,
which is a little bit annoying.
It'd be nice to simplify
instead of gadgets.
But that's the best
we have so far.
And you can use the regular
NCL crossover appropriately,
making everything else slower
so that crossover doesn't
slow things down too much.
Cool.
A couple more minutes.
I want to mention
a couple of games
that do not fit into the table.
In some sense, they are
higher than the table.
So we have polynomial
bounded number of moves.
And then, above that, we have
exponential number of moves.
But if you take those
exponential number of moves
and add an extra rule, so this
is entirely motivated by Go
with super-ko rule.
And you take any of these
games like G1 through G6.
So you have the same win rule.
But in addition you will lose
if you ever repeat a past game
configuration.
So it's forbidden to do that.
Then, Robson, same guy who
proved Go is EXPTIME hard,
proved that G1, G2, and
G3, and chess and checkers
become EXPSPACE
complete, which is cool.
That's a little harder.
And it makes sense
they're in EXPSPACE
because it can sort of walk
the graph in exponential space.
But they actually
become that hard.
And even crazier
to me is this rule.
It seems almost the same.
So we're going to have two
extra variables x and y, which
can appear in the formula.
And instead of
this lose rule, we
add this lose rule which is
if you ever repeat a past game
configuration-- and between
now and that past configuration
at most one of x and y have
changed and that in turn-- then
you lose.
So if both of them
get changed, you're
allowed to repeat it again.
I don't have a great intuition
why this makes the game even
harder, but it pushes it
up to the next level which
is double the exponential time.
AUDIENCE: This is
change and changed
back [INAUDIBLE] configuration?
PROFESSOR: Well, right.
One of them will
have changed, x or y.
Hm.
You're repeating
the configuration.
So you changed something--
it be some other variable z--
and then change it back.
As long as you didn't
also change both x and y,
that's considered invalid.
Once you change x and y, you
are free to repeat everything
again, until the next time
something gets repeated.
So I guess you have
to keep track of when
the x and y changes are.
So it's even harder to know
the history of the game,
which repeats are valid
and which are invalid.
In this case, all
that he could prove
is the G1 becomes double
the exponential time.
Cool.
I could say a little more.
In this world, it's probably
good to know this fun fact.
Normally, when we think
of non-determinism,
we think of an NP.
We have existential
quantifiers on the guesses.
If there's at least one branch
that works, then we're happy.
Then, we return, yes.
You could also think of
universal quantifiers, where
if all of the paths going out
of here end up with yes, then
we're happy.
You can also think of an
alternating guess machine,
or alternating lucky machine,
where every other time
it's an existential guess
branch and the opposite times
it's a universal guess branch.
That corresponds to two-player
games in a natural way.
Alternating polynomial time
thing corresponds to queue set.
So that would give you PSPACE.
Alternating polynomial time
gives you polynomial space.
Alternating polynomial space
gives you exponential time.
Alternating exponential time
gives you exponential space.
Alternating exponential
space gives you
double the exponential time.
So in fact, this
result is stated
as alternating exponential
space complete,
which is the same as
double exponential time.
So time and space are
interleaved in the natural way.
And if you add
alternation to one layer,
you get to the next layer.
So it's just fun facts.
And it's useful for
reasoning about these games.
One more class.
We've so far talked about
perfect information games,
where everybody knows all the
states of all the variables.
You can define a
private information
game, where you can
see some but not
all of your opponent's state.
You know all of your
variable settings.
In this setting, a slight
variation on G1 and G2.
We have to generalize the
formula's a little bit,
become double the exponential
time complete, just as hard
as the weird repeat rule.
Private information gives
you a very hard thing.
A more restricted form is when
player 1 can't see anything
about player 2.
But player 2 can see a
little bit of player 1.
This is sort of a
semi-blind game.
In this case, G2 at least is
exponential space complete.
That's weaker than here.
So lots of weird
separations here.
There are no well-known
games in these categories
that have been proofed hard.
But here is the version of Peek.
You can redesign
the Peek structure.
So you have some walls here.
So you can't see whether this
guy's in or this guy's out.
Player 0 can only
play on these guys.
Player 1 can only
plan on these guys.
Player 1 can see
all of this state,
a little bit of the state.
In the blind version, you can't
see anything to the right.
And because they
couldn't do G4, this
is the G2 version, which is
there's also a wall here.
And you can only see
red through these holes.
And your opponent can see
So you've got two
different win conditions.
That's G2.
And so that's a version of Peek.
This one is double
the exponential time
hard and complete.
And this one is
exponential space complete.
So these are like
way in the deep end.
But next class we'll talk
about this category of team
imperfect information games.
And then, we even
get undecidability,
which is the ultimate hardness.
But that's all for today.